على اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم التقارب العسكري
بين طهران وبيجين وموسكو وما المدى الذي
يمكن ان يصل اليه وما الذي يزعج واشنطن
والغرب من هذا التقارب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعتقد ان واشنطن
قلقه حول هذا التقارب والتعاون بين الصين
وروسيا وايران وهي دول معاديه للولايات
المتحده وتستخدم القوه العسكريه من اجل
تغيير الوضع في العالم بالتالي الامر مغلق
ايران تعطيه روسيا الاسلحه التي تستخدمها
في الانخراط في هذه الحرب الدمويه ضد
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ايران تريد ان تكون مصدره للاسلحه بالنظر
الى هذه السياسيه تسمح لها بتصدير الاسلحه
الى دول مثل روسيا والصين ودول اخرى من
ضمنها دول الجوار وهذا
مصمم بدايه وهذه السياسه مصممه من اجل
مكافحه ومواجهه العقوبات المفروضه على
ايران وعلى الطغيان والغربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الولايات المتحده ما تزال تمتلك حوالي 60%
من اجمالي الناتج المحلي ايران وروسيا
والصين يمتلكون حوالي 19% بالتالي
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها ما يزنون هم في
موقف متفوق حتى لو ان الصين وروسيا وايران
عملوا سويه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المتحده
كانت قد عادت ايران والصين وروسيا في نفس
الوقت هذه هي المره الاولى التي يحصل فيها
مثل هذا الشيء في التاريخ الحديث هذا
الامر يجعله من هذه الدول الثلاثه حلفاء
طبيعيين وهذا قد سمح
للدول الثلاثه تلك ان تتقارب مع بعضها
البعض والتوقيت مهم جدا لان العالم الان
يشهد تحولا نحو عالم متعدد الاطراف
[موسيقى]